قضيه اللاجئين السوريين كانت نقطه تبادل
الاتهامات بين اردوغان وكيليجار اوغلو لن
الجا اطلاقا الى خطاب الكراهيه في قضيه
طالب اللجوء مثل ما يفعلوا انه ينتهج
خطابا لا يقل حده عن الحقبه النازيه
الحكومه منحت الجنسيه لاناس لا يعرفون حتى
اللغه التركيه وهؤلاء هم من يحددون مستقبل
هذا البلد
اتهم خصمه بعرقله حملته الانتخابيه اذا
فاز السيد
فستفوز المنظمات الارهابيه وسماسره لندن
والشركات الامريكيه لا ينبغي ان نمنحهم
الفرصه بهدف ضمان وحدتنا وتضامننا
لقد حجبوا الرسائل النصيه لانهم خائفون
منا اسالك يا اردوغان الا تريدني ان اخوذ
هذه الانتخابات
اردوغان خصمه بالتعاون مع الارهابيين بعد
اجتماعك الجدار اوغلو مع حزبين كرديين
في غرف البرلمان التركي للتفاوض حول طريقه
التعامل مع الارهابيين خارج الحدود
يجب ان لا تصوتوا لمن ادخل البلاد في هذا
المستنقع توجهوا الى صناديق الاقتراع
واقترعوا وفقا لما يمليه عليكم ضميركم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات